el Debut se convirtió en una
controversia la primera que enfrenta
Richie sunat por el regreso al gobierno
de la ministra del interior suela
braverman quien fue forzada a renunciar
hace apenas una semana como ministra del
interior del issstras porque envió desde
su correo electrónico personal
información confidencial del gobierno a
un diputado conservador rompiendo
claramente el código ministerial es una
que defendió y dijo que fue un simple
problema de juicio pero lo cierto es que
los laboristas los han acusados una que
hablaba mal de tener acuerdos sucios y
han exigido una investigación sobre el
comportamiento de la ministra Lo cierto
es que sunat ha tenido que incluir a
suela barberman en su gabinete porque
ahora que está tratando de unir al
partido conservador sabe que ella es la
cara visible y la más importante de la
derecha de los Torres